As a new developer, you might be tempted to memorize a
certain click path in order to get some kind of process
done, but it's not always a good idea. Instead, it's better
to find the general area of where you want to get something
done, go there, and then figure it out. Let me explain
what I mean. The setup page is an important place to
go. It's where you go when you want to customize your app.
This Schema builder let's you visualize the objects and relationships and
add fields to them. It's a good place to go
to get the big picture view of what you're building. When
you click on an object, you get to the object
homepage, which is a good place to look at specific records.
When you click on a record, you get to the
record detail page. Which gives you specific information about that record.
The Quick Access menu gives you handy shortcuts to customizing
your application. And finally, there's the page layout editor which helps
you select the fields and display them in the order that you want them.
They'll run pretty quickly and you're not
going to remember everything I said. Sales Force
has a lot of ways to do something and if you click around, you're going to
find it. If you don't, try clicking the help link or use the discussion forums